cnn's brian stelter getting a taste of
his own medicine for a change confronted
by a college freshman on the
disinformation his network spews out on
a daily basis
they push the russian collusion hoax
they push the jesse smollett hoax they
smeared justice kavanaugh as a rapist
and they also smeared nick salmon as a
white supremacist and yes they dismissed
the hunter biden laptop affair as pure
russian disinformation all the mistakes
of the mainstream media and cnn in
particular
seem to magically all go in one
direction are we expected to believe
that this is all just some sort of
random coincidence it's too bad it's
time for lunch
you have 30 seconds no i think you're
describing a different channel than the
one that i watch
but i understand that that is a popular
right-wing narrative about cnn the last
time i spoke with a biden aide we yelled
at each other
so greg with your analysis are you
surprised that brian stelter's first
reaction would be to say that it's time
to go to lunch yeah i mean and it was
only 9 a.m right
he doesn't watch his own network i think
that's the well that's the first point
number two it's pretty funny to see cnn
hosting a symposium on disinformation
you know unless it's how to but it's a
parody of itself cnn's entire profit
model is not reporting news it's
creating news the producers shape the
narratives so that they're designed to
create content to fill up all of those
hours of empty space and empty heads
that's what the pro the problem with cnn
is that there isn't enough boring crap
to justify its existence this is why
their anchors became commentators
without ever being labeled as such at
fox we clearly delineate who's who's a
news person who's who's a who's a
commentator i chew the fat no offense
stelter i chew the fat
while bret bear and bill hammer
everybody else they report the news
everybody knows that we have a
relationship with the viewers so we
don't have to trick them with these
artificial narratives on a slow news day
we don't have to gin up conflict the
fact that he played dumb and maybe he
wasn't
well
it was it was kind of embarrassing
because the god the guy brought he got
he brought the evidence he listed every
story it wasn't like the kid walked up
and said why are you guys doing all that
fake news he went through and then he
made the most important point is that
every bias goes in one direction which
we've made that point many times i look
forward to seeing the young man
co-hosting fox and friends weekend in
2028. love it so martha that student did
list a number of stories brian stelter
fancies himself a media journalist who
covers the news
and they're desperate for credibility so
did he miss an opportunity here to try
and make amends and say maybe we could
have covered these things a little bit
differently
and these are the things we need to do
better next time yeah i mean and all of
those stories that he listed fell apart
every one of those stories which they
spent an enormous amount if they spent
as much time
investigating them as they did trying to
shove them down everyone's throat they
would have been doing some good
journalism and they would have figured
it out right and a number of those
stories you know we were skeptical on
from the beginning and you know made a
good effort to look at both sides of
this story um i i think it's hilarious
that he says like uh-huh time to go to
lunch and then he says after that to the
kid um to the young man he says um i'll
talk i'm gonna come out and talk to you
yeah after this we're gonna you may
we're gonna have a little a little
head-to-head and you know because i do
want to give you your due and i want to
make sure that i answer your questions
but he's not going to do it up there on
the on the podium and i and i just think
the title of this i'm so tired the
disinformation and the erosion of
democracy it's like subtitle right um
you know they're just praying that
president trump doesn't run again or
they're praying he does either way right
because their
ratings have tanked since they had uh
president trump to you know to poke at
every day um but this has just become
such a catchphrase that that means
exactly what everyone knows what it
means so jesse does the whole
misinformation disinformation isn't that
just code for
we don't like what's being said or being
held accountable and therefore we would
like censorship uh for any outlet or
media that doesn't agree with our
mistakes or our narrative yeah you
nailed it katie and you made some great
points so i'll be short
if you're how old is he what's he 45
yeah he's a grown man right he's a
student oh it's stealth filter no he's
like 12.
he's a young kid
isn't he young how old is he i'm gonna
go all right well you an 18 year old kid
shouldn't be able to leave you
speechless and and searching for a
coherent answer yeah you know you're a
grown man you're a professional you're
the ombudsman for cnn if you can't
handle a teenager you don't deserve to
be on air i will say he's a much better
writer
he
he's that's what it is yeah i told you
he was young he was on red eye he was in
college when he was doing actually oh i
thought he was okay never mind i don't
want to get into that sorry that's old
enough to be a mature human right but
you should be able to handle a college
freshman and i'm hearing from my sources
katie that he's not long for cnn that
they don't like him there so they might
actually cut him loose he did say
something that was interesting oh he
goes oh you know we have to apologize
when we get things wrong
he didn't apologize for any of that
stuff except i guess you could call the
sandman settlement yeah an apology but
that was just a payoff
so jessica a number of these students
did get organized they're from this
conservative outlet on campus called the
chicago thinker now the editor of the
atlantic is basically smearing them and
saying that their conference has been
attacked by disinformation as a result
of these students showing up and simply
asking questions in a forum where
they're supposed to be open on a college
campus to different ideas and
perspectives well especially at an
institution like the university of
chicago so we're talking about the the
top of the top here and um
i think that it's a good thing to be
pushed on these things i think you
should have an answer ready i always
have an answer ready if there's
something that i've brought up
i'm ready to defend it or at least to
say i was wrong about this and that's
why i have been cautious about certain
scandals now we don't have time for this
and i don't want to talk about it again
like for me and for many people have the
same political beliefs as me
what came out of the mueller probe was
not a hoax it wasn't and mueller made it
clear in his 2019 testimony on top of it
that he did not exonerate donald trump
not guilty
okay but that's not the point here what
happened
in that meeting and with ann applebaum
earlier in the week
says something about where the country
is going because of how young people are
and gen z's and younger millennials are
not interested in traditional party
politics they're interested in being
persuaded and they want people with the
kind of ideas that align with their
values so they care about things like
the environment even young republicans
care more about climate change and
believe that it's man-made than older
republicans and it's the responsibility
of politicians and of media outlets to
make sure that they're taking these
young people seriously in order to make
them either loyal viewers or people who
come out and vote for you and i think
that that's a lot of the missed
opportunity that goes on at these
conferences when people just kind of
send them to the side and say you know
this is bs whatever this one is saying
because it's not my political alignment
um this is the new face of
of our generations this is what gen z is
people from the conference who are
supposed to be leaders in journalism did
themselves any favors by having an
arrogant reaction to questions from
young journalists who are writing and
interested in these issues and asking
questions hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else